ERIC KOLEDA: Our team's job is
to make sure people that are
using Google Developer products
are happy and
successful.
And this show is all
about Apps Script.
Our main purpose here is to
answer your questions.
If you're watching live, you
can either join the Live
Hangout, come join me, and we'll
answer some questions.
Or if you don't feel like
joining, if you're a little
shy, you can go to the embedded
Moderator page, which
is inside of this event,
and start typing
your questions there.
And I'll go through them
during the show.
Before we get started with
questions and answers, I
wanted to just cover a little
bit of some news that's
happened recently in the
Apps Script community.
One thing is that we recently
published a blog post early
this week on Monday about
how the-- it's
very exciting, actually--
the UK, their cabinet office,
the ministers in that office,
are actually using-- well, not
the ministers programming
themselves, but the more
techie members of their
office-- actually have been
putting together a solution to
create custom reports on their
Google Analytics data.
So they have a number of
different web properties that
they're trying to monitor
analytics on.
And the ministers need their
information in a certain
format on a daily basis so they
can easily digest and get
some information about it.
And so for that purpose, they
put together some Apps Script
code that pulls a report
directly from Google Analytics
using the integration that's in
Apps Script, puts that into
some spreadsheets, does
some formatting and
manipulation of the data.
And then from there, they output
that into a Design tool
that produces the final
stylized report.
So go check it out.
It's on our blog.
You can search for the Google
Apps Developer Blog, that's
probably the easy
way to find it.
But it's also
Googleappsdeveloper.blogs.com.
Just go take a look.
It's actually really exciting.
And we've seen a lot of people
recently get success by using
Apps Script to pull data
from Google Analytics.
I think people who use Google
Analytics, power users, they
love data, they love
number crunching.
And Spreadsheets in Apps Script
is the perfect tool set
to kind of comb through that
data, refine it, and pull out
interesting metrics.
So do check that out.
And some other things, if you're
new to some of these
Google Developer Live episodes
we've been doing.
We've done one just this week
which was an introduction to
Apps Script triggers.
So triggers are a method by
which your Apps Script code
can, rather than run when you
tell it to, react to an event.
Either react to something
happening in a spreadsheet or
a form being submitted or even
just every once in awhile.
So kind of like on
a regular timer.
This is a great way that you
can take a task, let's say,
that you want to check something
or manipulate
something on a set
period of time.
Rather than having to go into
some interface and click a
button, triggers allow you
to do it automatically.
My colleague, Ikai, did a really
great episode about how
to use triggers.
He showed off some cool demos.
So you can check that out on the
Google Developers YouTube
channel, just search for
Apps Script triggers.
And along those lines, we have
two other special GDLs like
this coming up in the next
couple of weeks.
Next week we're doing one about
integrating Google Apps
Script with Twilio.
If you haven't used Twilio,
it's not a Google product,
it's another company altogether,
that makes a
really developer-friendly
API for interacting
with SMS and Voice.
So it's kind like a bridge you
can use to send messages to
phones, receive phone calls,
receive text messages.
It's really powerful and allows
for a lot of cool
integrations.
It's no longer just that your
script can be stuck in a
spreadsheet.
It's now accessible on your
phone and beyond.
So it's really kind
of a neat thing.
And so my colleague, Arun,
is going to be
presenting on that.
And you could find that on the
Google Developers Live page,
which you can search for.
This one is called Adding Voice
and SMS to Google Apps
using Twilio in Apps Script.
And then one more of those that
we have, this is a little
bit in the future now.
I think it's about
two weeks out.
We're doing one on using Charts
Dashboards with Apps Script.
So as we mentioned, it's usually
the people who love
data that are doing things
in Apps Script.
And one of the best things you
can do with data is display
some charts.
It's a great way to visually,
in an instant, see
trends in the data.
And so along those lines, Apps
Script supports some
capabilities of the
Google Charts API.
And one of those that we do
support is Dashboards.
Dashboards are really great in
that they allow you to take
your data set and display one
data set in a number of charts
and then add controls that
allow you to dynamically
filter which data is
being displayed.
And so that was something we
added to Google Apps Script a
couple of months ago.
And we've seen some people
really excited about it.
So we're going to do an episode
just dedicated to
Charts and Dashboards by
my colleague Kalyan.
And that will be coming to
you in couple weeks.
So stay tuned.
All of this, like I said,
is on the Google
Developers Live page.
You can go there and look for
our Apps Script GDLs.
So that's about it
on the news.
Let's go to your questions.
Let's see if we have anybody
in the Hangout that has any
questions today.
Welcome, does anybody in the
Hangout have any questions.
Well, if you do have questions,
feel free to chime
in in a little bit.
We'll keep your audio
on there.
So just chime in.
And if you have any questions,
we'll answer them.
But until then, feel free
to tune in and listen to
what's going on.
We do have some questions in the
Google Moderator asked by
some of our users
ahead of time.
There's actually some really
great ones about scriptdb.
We have two questions
about scriptdb.
So scriptdb is a built-in data
store to Apps Script.
It's a JavaScript object
data store.
So it's kind of putting objects
in, and then querying
for them later.
It's not very similar to SQL.
It works a little
bit differently.
But the same basic pattern,
store something, get it back.
And so the questions we have
here, the first one is in
scriptdb if I store an object
containing functions, let's
say, like to find in the
constructor of an object, the
user here noticed that they're
lost when you store it and
then later retrieve
it from scriptdb.
He sees that the functions
come back as just plain
strings sometimes.
He's like is that inevitable?
Is there no way to do class
definitions and store those
into scriptdb?
And unfortunately, the short
answer there is, yes.
In JavaScript you can create
objects that have both data
and functions just
like you can in
other programming languages.
However, when you convert a
JavaScript object to JSON, the
JavaScript Object Notation,
functions are not preserved.
Only data is preserved.
And this is the underlying
technology of scriptdb.
And so what it means is if you
have an object that has some
data and some functions and
you stored it in scriptdb,
that function, those
functions, are
all going to be lost.
It's just the nature of how JSON
works is that functional
code exists when it's in memory,
but it can't persist
when you go JSON.
So that is a limitation.
I think if you wanted to work
with that, if you wanted to
have complex objects, store
them, and bring them up later,
you'd have to do a little
bit of extra work.
Like, for instance, have the
constructor for an object take
in all the data that was their
previously, put that into the
right places, and then
have the rest of
the functions there.
So there are probably some
workarounds if you're skilled
at JavaScript and
object-oriented programming in
JavaScript that you could put
the data into scriptdb, pull
it out, and then merge it back
in with the functions later.
It's going to take a little
bit of work though.
And then another question here
about scriptdb is they want to
know is it possible to store
an object that references
another one that's already been
stored without having to
store it once again as a copy.
So I guess what they're talking
about here is you have
some sort of upper-level object
that has then maybe an
array of children objects
inside of it.
And those children objects, he
said, are already in scriptdb,
but he wants to maintain this
linkage that the parent object
has some children.
And there is no way for
scriptdb to do this
automatically where you could
just tell it that this is in
there, and then when you pull
it out, it will all link up
again magically.
Unfortunately, that's not
going to happen today,
scriptdb is very
straightforward in that regard.
So I think your best bet would
be rather than to store a copy
of these objects or to hope
for some linking,
rather store the IDs.
So if you already have stored
the child objects, you got an
ID at the time that
you stored them.
Use those IDs as keys, and store
the keys inside of your
parent object.
So when you retrieve the parent,
when you look into the
array of children, you'll
see there's a whole
bunch of keys there.
You'll then need to make a
second call to scriptdb to
fetch all the children out
So when you're working with
a more complex objects
structure, it's going to take
some additional requests to
scriptdb, but it's certainly
possible to
achieve the end result.
And so the last one--
I'll share another one we have
here in the Moderator is
somebody who's creating a
script for a number of
different Google Sites or
creating a script that creates
Google Sites using the Sites
app that we have built into
Apps Script.
And they're wondering
how can I test if a
site already exists?
What they're using today is
they're using a URLfetch,
which is our service for just
making basic HTTP requests, to
actually fetch the site and see
if there's anything there.
So they know what the URL should
be if the site exists,
but they just don't know if it
actually was created yet, and
so they're fetching it
to see if it's there.
They're wondering is
there a better way.
I think that's actually
not a terrible way.
Making one HTTP request to
determine if something is
there is not that bad.
It may be possible
using Sites app.
You could fetch a list of all
your sites, comb through that
list and see if this site
is there or not.
That's another thing
you could do.
But as far as which is
better, I think you
could go either route.
Probably sticking with Sites
app is going to be the most
straightforward if someone
is reading
your code in the future.
But it's really up to your own
decision making there.
So there was a couple
from the Moderator.
Just to make sure people in
the Hangout don't have any
questions, I'm going to
throw it back to them.
You guys in the Hangout have
any questions for me today?
Any Apps Script problems
bugging you?
All right, that's good news then
if there's no problems.
All right, so we do have one
more question here in the
Moderator which I'll field.
And feel free to jump in guys in
the Hangout if you have any
additional questions.
So the question here was are
there any plans to add
services like Voice or Payment
into Apps Script?
So, yeah, I mean, certainly what
we love about Apps Script
is it's a great way to integrate
a whole bunch of
Google services really easily.
Built in, and with no additional
work required, you
can access Gmail, you can access
Calendar, Sites, your
Docs, your Drive, Spreadsheets,
it's all there.
But by all, it's not everything
that Google offers.
So we do have some other
services at Google, like
Voice, like Payments that aren't
right now built into
Apps Script.
And it's really, I think, part
of our goal to make sure that
Apps Script continues to be a
great place to integrate,
continues to be a great
place to work with
these different services.
So I don't think we're ever
going to shut the door on
bringing more services on board,
but at this time I
really don't have any specific
plans about when you could
expect to see those
in Apps Script.
I'd say there's one thing that's
probably going to--
if you want a guideline for when
you could expect to see
some in Apps Script, if they're
already is an API for
it that exists outside of Apps
Script, it's certainly going
to be a lot easier for
the team to bring
it into Apps Script.
So if you see an API that Google
already produces and
you want to access that same
functionality in Apps Script,
you're probably going to have a
better chance of requesting
that one and seeing some action
than if there never was
an API in the first place just
because of how things are
implemented on our side.
But that was a good question.
And I think as the Twilio GDL
that we're doing next week
indicates, integrating with
Voice and Text is obviously an
important use case for
some people and
really opens some doors.
So it would be great if you
could access Google Voice,
which does some of those same
functionalities, but today
that's just not there.
So that is all the questions
that I have here in the
Moderator One last chance
for the Hangout folks.
If you have any questions,
feel free to jump in now.
AUDIENCE: I want to
ask a question.
What is the best practice to
disable all the components in
a vertical panel or a form
panel right now?
Because there isn't a
functionality to disable all
the Widgets of the [INAUDIBLE],
for example.
I mean, one cord to disable all
the same Widget of, for
example, a particular panel
in a full panel.
ERIC KOLEDA: I'm sorry, my ear
piece was a little low.
I had trouble hearing you.
So you wanted to disable
certain functionality?
Can you say again which
functionality you were
interested in?
AUDIENCE: A functionality to
disable all the chart region
of a full panel.
For example, I have two text
boxes in a full panel and a
Submit button.
When I click the Submit button,
I want all the Widget,
the chart of the component, for
example, with the one to
be disabled.
ERIC KOLEDA: I see.
So I guess the situation,
if I'm guessing--
AUDIENCE: Right now, I'm able to
store all video of the Chat
Widget and disable them with,
for example, our full cycle.
ERIC KOLEDA: Right.
Yeah, I guess you have to do it
individually and remember
which Widgets are in there.
Yeah, I can see what
you're saying.
So is the use case that when
someone clicks that button,
there's going to be a little
bit of a delay in the
processing and you don't
want people to
change the form values?
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
ERIC KOLEDA: What
is the purpose
of doing the disabling?
Why is that a good thing?
AUDIENCE: For example, I use to
disable all the component
in a user insert case where I
have to show all this pull out
of the full panel.
Because some people have to see
a part of the full panel
and other people have all
the [INAUDIBLE] to them.
So I have a different front
panel and each of the front
panel based on if the app user
is a part of a group, I
disable or enable
a full panel.
ERIC KOLEDA: I see.
OK, yeah, I guess I can
see that is a little
bit of extra work.
You can't just disable a whole
panel at once, you have to do
it on widget-by-widget basis.
That's something we can
look into as far
as requesting that.
I'd say that for some of the
feature requests, where if
it's possible to do it and it
just requires a little of
extra code, those usually aren't
as high priority when
there's something that people
really want to do and it's
just impossible to do.
So for something like this, it's
still a good idea, and
it's still something
we can definitely
talk to the team about.
But I would say for the time
being, you're probably going
to have to work with
what's there.
But that said, about feature
requests just in case we have
some people new on the episode
today, if you use Apps Script
a lot, and there's a feature
that's really missing or that
you think would be really great
to have, we have an
issue tracker which is for
logging both bugs with the
product and also features.
So if there's a feature
you'd like to see, go
to our issue tracker.
You can get to it from our
documentation, and just fill
in what the feature is that
you'd like to see and why you
think it's really important.
And then we'll continue to
monitor that and see if
there's enough interest
and if it's possible.
AUDIENCE: OK.
No, I have already reported
this enhancement.
ERIC KOLEDA: Fantastic.
Yeah, we're a little behind on
coming through some of those,
but we're catching
up this week.
So hopefully, we'll get to that
one in just a little bit.
All right, great.
Let me just check the moderator
one more time.
It's looks like there are
no new questions.
One last chance on
the Hangout.
No.
Sounds like we're all good.
All right.
Well, thanks everyone for
joining me today.
We'll be back--
I don't know if we'll
be back next week.
Probably not next week.
But certainly after
the holidays.
Obviously, during the holidays
things get a little
complicated.
But certainly after the
holidays, we'll back in the
New Year with a whole bunch more
episodes of Office Hours.
And as we mentioned, in the
coming weeks we'll also have
some special additions of our
Apps Script episodes focused
on particular topics.
So in the meantime, if you have
questions about how to
use Apps Script, me and the rest
of the team, we're all on
the Stack Overflow monitoring
the Google-apps-script tag.
So tag your questions
with that.
There's a whole great community
out there of other
users who will be able
to help you.
And we'll chime in if nobody
else knows the answer.
So until then, thank you very
much for joining me, and I'll
see you later.